hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of Molly the monsters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow a business is to
model the strategies of people who have
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're going to look at how a young
entrepreneur followed his passion for
computers and in one weekend created the
code for a new website that would go on
to be one of the most popular websites
in the world this is the story of eBay
founder Pierre Omidyar and a top three
lessons that you can learn from his
success Pierre Omidyar is an American
entrepreneur and philanthropist
economist and the founder chairman of
eBay growing up he became fascinated
with computers and often skipped gym
class in school to play on their
computers after graduating high school
and university he went to work for an
Apple subsidiary to develop software for
the Macintosh Omidyar soon felt the
entrepreneur itch and wanted to start
his own business when Omidyar was 28
years old he stayed in front of his
computer for the entire Labor Day long
weekend and wrote the original code for
eBay originally called auction web
Omidyar wanted to change the name to
echo Bay and drive to Sacramento to
register the name when he arrived he
found Echo Bay was already registered so
we decided to go with eBay on the spot
instead of having to make a return trip
today eBay has revenues of over nine
billion dollars and Omidyar serves as
its chairman he has an estimated net
worth of six point seven billion dollars
making him the 50th richest person in
the world and it all began with one long
weekend writing code and launching a new
website
by following his passion and computers
and by actually taking action on the
idea that he had Pierre Omidyar was able
to build one of the most successful
companies in his industry to help you
make your company more successful
here are three action items you can
learn from Pierre Omidyar action item
number one just go for it you know what
one thing every successful entrepreneur
has in common they got started you may
have great business ideas but if you
never take action on them you have
nobody but yourself to blame don't be
afraid to try something different and
fail you will know failure keep trying
and experimenting with little projects
until you strike gold and can really run
with your new business idea Omidyar had
a lot of people who never thought his
website would ever take off why would
complete strangers be willing to buy and
sell to each other online how would they
trust each other to complete the deal
when they are believed that people were
fundamentally good people and would be
for the most part honorable he kept at
it and intended to prove his critics
wrong when we do I realized it was
working when he started earning more
money from eBay than from his day job
according to Omidyar I started eBay as
an experiment as a side hobby basically
while I had my day job a lot of people
don't just go ahead and try things
they'll have an idea and they'll say
they'll convince themselves or other
people will convince them that it can't
be done I just kind of had this naive
approach to well gee you know why not
I'll just go ahead and do it don't let
people who you may respect and who you
believe know what they're talking about
don't let them tell you it can't be done
because often they'll tell you it can't
be done and it's just because they don't
have the courage to try you're able to
accomplish anything you set out to
accomplish
action atom number two follow your
passion
almost every famous entrepreneur gives
similar advice do what you're passionate
about when you love what you do
you'll make a far better product or
service and will have a much bigger
impact on your target market
don't waste time trying out businesses
that you're not really interested in
just because it can make you money focus
your energy and talent on what you're
uniquely able to create and you're on
your way to building a successful
business from the time he was a young
boy Omidyar knew that his future lied in
computers he didn't know how or when but
when the other boys were outside playing
sports Omaha was busy teaching himself
computer programming languages like
basic if he didn't follow his passion
and tried to force himself into other
areas that didn't interest him the world
would never have come to known eBay
according to Omidyar I always wanted to
be involved with computers I was just
pursuing what I enjoyed doing I was
pursuing my passion it's not work really
if you're having fun that was the case
with me you have to really believe in
what you're doing
be passionate enough about it so you'll
put in the hours and the hard work that
it takes to actually succeed there and
then you'll be successful action item
number three be nice a lot of people
think that business is cutthroat but it
doesn't have to be when I hire people
one of the core values that we look for
is is this person nice it's amazing how
much more productive you are and how
much more fun you have when you enjoy
working with the people around you your
staff your customers and your suppliers
Omidyar founded eBay with the belief
that nice guys finish first
he created a set of core values for the
business based on honesty and building
trusted relationships he also believed
that if his company could live by those
core values then they would attract
customers who felt the same way to date
his theory has proven to be correct
there are only thirty out of every
million transactions that happen on eBay
where people file a fraud complaint
according to Omid yar I founded the
company on the notion that people were
basically good
and then if you give them the benefit of
the doubt you're really disappointed
nice guys a responsible company that has
its heart in the right place that's run
by real human beings it has to be
successful because if we weren't that
way
eBay wouldn't be successful eBay
wouldn't exist it wouldn't be possible
so remember just go for it
follow your passion and be nice to
finish up this video I wanted to share
one of my favorite true stories about
Pierre Omidyar and some of his best
quotes eBay was originally hosted on a
website that Omidyar had created with
information about the Ebola virus the
site originally allowed buyers and
sellers to connect for free but as the
site grew he had to charge a small fee
only our hope that the transaction fees
would eventually be enough to cover his
web site hosting costs
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling masters if you guys
like the video please leave a comment
below I love hearing your constant
feedback and it also really appreciate
any thumbs up so you want to give to the
video and stay tuned to the next episode